good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday after
thanksgiving break
we are back in studio hello jacqueline
hi i'm excited to be back in studio
though this is such a monday i mean for
everyone we just had a four day weekend
and now we're back to work but we have
so much to discuss here at the toast
today it's a big day i'm looking forward
to leaving it all on the couch you know
i definitely feel better because we were
able to podcast in the middle of the
week so much like loki happened last
week like celebrity wise we did a
patreon episode fast five of like things
we just had to talk about right and if
you're looking for like the the bachelor
drama if you're looking for what else we
talk about dancing with the stars recap
like if you're looking for all of that
it's on the patreon patreon.com morning
toast it's irrelevant by today i know so
i'm glad we got to discuss it so we
didn't have to like bring up old [ __ ]
yeah i agree we talked about emma from
selling sunset we had some great patreon
episodes we did there's still one more
coming this month but we got olivia on
the patreon yesterday which is always a
pleasure we did our fast five business
news stories actually just like world
news stories for your thanksgiving table
but you know what that episode is
applicable through the holiday season
because if you're seeing family if
you're seeing people if you're middling
at a dinner party these are
conversations topics and like
ice-breaking questions that you should
have in your back pocket we're also
tackling big conversations like
inflation which is really an evergreen
concept yeah art
art crime like so many so many different
subjects quite informative so i do feel
good that we were able to unload some of
that [ __ ] on the patreon like we don't
have so much catching up to do but we
still have a lot of catching up to do so
much television you and i both finished
the new season of selling sunset which
we will put in the tv recap also the
real house was a potomac finish last
night and i watched the jonas brothers
roast and i absolutely have to talk to
someone about it i want to hear all
about it but i am going to watching it i
watched it so absolutely nobody else on
the planet has to i can't i can't i know
it was that bad it was really bad like
borderline atrocious i can't believe it
i need to find out for myself okay it
was the [ __ ] you hate
clickbaity like oh they go to a spin
class like all of it was like these
pre-recorded packages that like keenan
kept throwing she was like very james
corden like it was really bad and the
best part was pete davidson and they
gave him four seconds to roast and you
just needed more john legend was fine
the wives were okay like it was really
bad like it was very very very not good
well can i tell you something that's
going to cheer you up in some good
content news
annie live is this week i know you guys
annie live is this week and annie's
making news because she performed at the
thanksgiving day parade oh my god i had
to watch i i didn't turn it on early
enough to see her but i heard she was
amazing i knew the reviews are in
everyone lip syncs so like really how
good could she have been but maybe
whatever she recorded the reviews are in
and apparently anna is a star
and it bodes really well for annie live
okay but here's the thing
the thing is is that i have a show
the night of annie live i believe i'm
gonna be in detroit okay so annie dvr'd
it's not the same no it's not the same
are you gonna watch of course
live you know what maybe i'll i need to
get myself like a screener even though
it's live like you can't
but i need to get it so i can watch it
on thursday night like after my show
treat myself okay i have a three hour
drive to toronto you can use my youtube
tv login
youtube
and you can watch it like on your phone
then i need wi-fi right whatever i'll
figure it out you'll see anything for
amazon it's a big week annie live i
start my tour this week i have three
enormous shows minneapolis detroit
toronto tickets available at girl no
job.com there's no tickets in
minneapolis or toronto but detroit is
that one show i told you guys that won't
sell out so head over come on
comm slash tour take a trip and i also
did a show on saturday i did a patreon
little practice show my last one
such a good crowd i heard it was a great
show it it really was like i'm not one
to two my own horn i know what i'm good
at and i know what i'm bad at and i was
so good on saturday that's so exciting
yeah so now i really feel like prepared
enough to tackle these these are big
theaters like a thousand people each i
am ready i'm excited i'm very nervous
but it's going to be a great week and i
no longer have that enormous pit in my
stomach like this is now something i'm
looking forward to that is you love to
hear it you do we really do we're we're
sending you off with so much love and
excitement and i look forward to hearing
all the reviews so the schedule for this
week is monday tuesday wednesday in
studio regular business thursday podcast
only friday
i am too busy to podcast and jackie's
pregnant so yeah you guys he's the
pregnant woman she's getting big you are
you really kind of
blew up i exploded exploded over
thanksgiving no i mean it for me it's
really been you also don't dress like
this like for the toast no but i got
this um shirt from the gap it's
maternity because i needed maternity
pajamas because the waistbands on all of
my pajamas were
yeah it was too tight so i was like i
need
maternity so the waistband is flex and
then i saw these cute little tops i was
like how chic so now i have more
maternity clothes and that's why you'll
catch me out here with my belly you're
looking like majorly pregnant now
whereas you usually just wear like a
crew neck i usually wear it just toast
merch by the way um shopmorningtoast.com
we're having our biggest black friday
cyber monday sale ever it's criminal
what's going on at the website okay it's
criminal we worked so hard and now we're
literally giving [ __ ] away for free
we're giving things away
um
everything that is not new is up to four
is 40 off or more more by the way almost
50. the stocking is 15 off so 40 percent
off sale black friday cyber monday today
cyber monday so head over to
shopmorningtoast.com you can get the new
holiday collection you can get the new
fall collection and then you can also
you know a la carte add some three
dollar pop sockets do you know what else
you can get now at shopmorningtoast.com
my tour merch i heard so i will be
having select merch at this the shows
but if you want to get stuff before
you're worried you might not get your
size it's all available online now
there's also more [ __ ] online than we
will be bringing to shows like more
designs so shop morning toast.com if you
go to the menu there's a little thing
that says not like other girls and we
made really cool merch for the tour so
you can get it at the show or you can
also get it online before um so there's
just lots of things to be purchasing at
shopmorningtoast.com there are and as
far as the holiday collection goes we
still have robes we still have blankets
we still have earmuffs i love those
earmuffs so much i wore them in today
they're a premium quality yeah they're
so stinking cute so
head over there get your tings and did
you do any black friday cyber monday
shopping not a thing
not one single thing i
i perused because i always you know [ __ ]
the bed yeah and it's like okay you
should spend it getting like something
that you've really wanted and like a big
purchase yeah what i want is an air
fryer but i don't have space for it so
okay um i have an air fryer and i don't
have space for it and it's something you
make space for like it's really no
especially in your like cooking it's the
most premium thing and by the way
they're really not expensive the one
that we got was like 90 bucks and it
works very very well
of course you can get like the four
hundred dollar one that's also like an
oven but just gonna get it for cyber
monday then yeah actually i get some
good um targeted ads for like crazy
airfryers get one it will change your
life okay cool also spritz society is
having a major
25 bfcm sale that's what the kids are
calling in in the industry go over them
to their instagram to get the unique
promo code i think i don't want to miss
say it so it's on the sports society
instagram yeah just like
no like it's one of those things where
you just click the link and applies the
code you know no you have to apply the
code no no not if you click the link are
you sure i'm positive or you can you
know go to society.com and apply the
code
got it bfcm 25 is the code but you can
also click the link in our bio yeah so
check that out it's great to celebrate
the holiday season with spirits and if
you are going over to a dinner party or
someone's hosting you a perfect gift
it's way more fun than a bottle of wine
and contains more alcohol content that's
true
also
we just have so much catching up
right after this i like cannot focus on
today's episode i'm conducting an
interview for tomorrow's episode
that might be
the one i've maybe felt the most
pressure to perform like i'm
interviewing someone i'm so sad you
can't be there but i understand why um
i'm very nervous about who i'm
interviewing for the toast right after
this it's going to be amazing
i'm so excited for you to flex your
diane sawyer chops no like literally
you're very prepared
you took the time and it's going to be
so great it's going to be so fun for you
because it's someone who you love
so much if you guys listen to the show
once you find out who it is it's like
one of claudia's favorite bravo labs of
all time and someone i've really just
kind of worked hard to
defend and like
like spread the good word about because
this person you know has been
villainized at some points and i'm just
i'm really looking forward to first of
all meeting her and thanking her for her
work yeah you know i'm excited for you
you guys will find out who it is
tomorrow and it's going to be great so
we have a busy week sales interviews
tour pregnancies such as children such a
busy week you know i had the craziest
dream i told you i woke up at 6 30. okay
you're gonna die at what i did today
okay
well you know how we were talking about
like dreams we just reveal so much okay
this i would love some help in revealing
what this says so i
me and ben had a baby but like it wasn't
our baby it was like a child that like
we both parented but like we weren't
like accepting it as like our child and
like we got it from home from the
hospital ben accidentally like kicked
the baby off the bed i forgot to feed
the baby i could see the baby's ribs it
was like really giving me it was the
worst dream ever okay do you think it
had to do with the dog that you saw
yesterday i don't know but i just want
to let you know i woke up super early
couldn't go back to bed which is like
such a not not like me thing like i can
always go back to bed so i was like is
my body telling me i'm pregnant even
though there's like no way i got up i
took a pregnancy yeah
i'm not pregnant
i just like
it was so unlike me to wake up and not
be able to go back to sleep it was such
a bothersome dream yeah that i was like
is this my body they always say like
when you know your body tells you you're
pregnant i'm like is this my body
telling me i'm pregnant oh that's an
interesting sign but it's not okay cool
it was a really traumatizing morning
i've been up forever that's nice for you
i'm at the phase of pregnancy where like
now my sleep has really been compromised
like i was so looking forward to this
last week because i was like i'm going
to sleep till the cows come home never
slept less in my life why the [ __ ] is my
[ __ ] life yeah so
that's that's really hard for me because
you guys know like sleep is my priority
favorite activity under the sun you
better get used to it yeah no that's the
body you know getting you prepared for
like other like i literally wake up
every single hour i sleep as light as a
feather now
sucks but it's just so funny that's
nature doing its thing preparing you for
when you need to be sleeping lightly
because you're taking care of a life do
you
can you take melatonin or something
not i haven't looked into it and i
wouldn't i wouldn't want to take it
that's really
definitely turning me off to children
like no sleep even when you're pregnant
like it hasn't even started no but i've
been sleeping pretty good up until now
maybe this is just a phase are you using
the pillow
i use the pillow
for lounging not for sleeping i laid my
ass in that pillow it is fabulous i
think you should just get a pregnancy
pillow like for life no like you're like
pregnant by proxy literally and
as i've said so many times like being
pregnant is the thing for you no i know
except for like the after part where
like you have the children you have to
raise them and like be selfless and like
look ugly you know i guess but you could
do it your own way i mean look at
christine totally we're gonna talk about
selling sunset but also
one last thing
and i hate to bring this up because i
know
it pains you but i'm going to luke combs
concert tonight
you know i've done a lot of self work
about this and i
i've i'm going to try and
be there for you guys
you don't have to but no i would
understand i don't think i'm going to
mute your stories like i think i'm going
to try to like push through and watch
them because
i'm just so excited for you and so
so so jealous i know i'm really do you
think that like if it weren't for covid
would you as a pregnant person go to a
concert okay so it's the covent element
yes okay but also like doesn't it sound
like torture like standing around with
your belly no it doesn't okay because
one you can sit at a concert so true you
really can and like for me just the
feeling of like the music the it's like
a serotonin boost that is worth whatever
back pain i'm gonna go home with which i
would have anyway yeah that's true okay
um but also you know what i just figured
out about the concert which i'm now not
i really don't want to like talk about
and make it but i don't know this will
not probably not make you that jealous
um do you know who the opener is
i think someone i like have recently
fallen in love with brandy carlisle nope
similar vibe actually
yeah that's
they're literally the same person
because they both get nominated for
grammys in the country department but
they're not like that big of stars yeah
um i'm ashley mcbride's number one fan
and i cannot wait i'm like texting the
group chat i'm like we have to get there
at 7 15. like ashley i will not miss a
second of actually mcbride that'll be so
great i'm excited for you i'm really
gonna i'm we're really gonna miss you
like on the energy of course will not be
the same yeah without but it's like if i
could do anything right now eat anything
you know do any go anywhere not like
activity that you can't ski eat sushi
drink
i would want to go to a luke homes
concert that would be my number one
thing i'm so sorry it's it's not right
yeah so it'll be okay i'm really happy
for you guys and just make sure the
stories are premium you know the story
oh the instagram stories yeah of course
yeah like so that we can feel like we're
there if anyone else is at home well
this is your reminder luke holmes is
doing two nights at madison square
garden don't miss it yeah i'm sure it's
sold out but step up
okay so now i feel caught up personally
professionally
emotionally physically and also
spiritually um
so let's dive right in i'm sorry no no
one more thing that we had i told you
about this yesterday
asked me how my weekend was
oh you guys claudia needs to unburden
herself i do she did something
embarrassing
claudia how was your weekend
it was really good until
i fell
i fell claudia has been doing this thing
it's been happening to me for years
where she is like in the in a cool party
in the coolest place you know with the
coolest people and she [ __ ] takes a
tumble and like a real like knees on the
ground like face hit the floor like like
it's amazing i'm walking today on all
fours just the pinnacle of embarrassment
so there there's many many many times
that i've fallen but there's three that
stand out in particular and
unfortunately one of them happened two
days ago
so the first one i was at a dinner party
and i was like drink and the thing is
with all these like yes i'm drinking but
i'm not wasted i can't stand i just have
less inhibitions and like my baby you're
not counting stairs and i'm like i'm a
clumsy person so i don't want it to be
like i'm stumbling all over the place
but yes i have had drinks so the first
time i fell at a dinner party i sat down
and i missed my chair and i fell
completely on the floor my ass and it
was like really embarrassing it's like a
lot of people were crowding around me
like are you okay and i'm like i'm fine
please don't look at me like [ __ ] off
okay that was years ago
that is so horrible this second one
which i think is the worst but the one
from saturday might be the worst one
when i was in vegas like a couple months
ago um i went to see paris dj and then
she had like a cute little after party
dinner it was like in this private room
not a lot of people maybe 20 people and
this time yeah i was blacked out and i
was wearing these huge platforms and i
don't know at some point in the night i
just went flying face first like nose
dive into some man's feet like and the
worst part was like ben wasn't there no
one was there to help me up so i laid on
the floor for like an extra second like
to get my bearings because it's very
shocking to fall and if ben was there he
usually just scoops me up but that the
paris one i think is the worst one i
don't know who saw when i when i fall
like i can't look around i can't make
eye contact like i don't want i somehow
think there's like a possibility that
nobody saw you know yeah well if i was a
spectator in the situation i know people
think like oh my god the first thing you
should do is like try and help the best
thing you can do is look away yeah
pretend like you didn't see that will
spare the person the most so then on
saturday
i had a very very bad fall um i was at
an after party and it was late and i had
been drinking
and i was there was like an outdoor area
and i walked from the outside to the
inside and there was like this little
ledge like nothing crazy but i was
wearing these huge platforms i missed
the little ledge and i went face first
into the floor and thankfully ben was
there i wasn't on the ground for more
than a second before ben scooped me up
but i was like fully laying on my back
like
looking up at the party and it was
terror and it ruined my whole day
yesterday all i kept thinking was like
who saw like did people see i was a girl
who fell
and
it's a life ruiner and i don't know how
to stop falling that's the thing yeah i
want to you know take something away
from this maybe it's the big shoes
maybe it's a drinking no it's not either
because i literally cannot wear like
anything but big shoes look at my shoes
right now they're [ __ ] huge yeah
that's just who i am you want me to not
be who i am well if who you are is a
faller then is that who you want to be i
just think like i need to it just it
always hits me when i don't expect it
the fall so i just feel like i need to
just keep it top of mind always but like
i'm drinking i'm talking to people i'm
not thinking don't fall you know yeah no
i used to have a real fear of falling in
college because you were huge shoes i
wore huge shoes and not even at night
like not even drunk falling but like
falling on the quad like on the ice
because i was always just like not
wearing the right shoes but i was just
making it like a statement of course and
i was just so worried that i was going
to embarrass myself so thoroughly and
also like they would say like i call it
like because it's hilly and i see like
everybody falls it's it's like it's a
rite of passage
and when i finally had my fall was it
with the bike no oh that's the best but
that's a different ball no this was like
a fall like you know in the near the
academic buildings on the slippery
slope and it was as good it was fine
there was no one around i fell in my
tushy there was a railing right nearby
oh my goodness
it was so fun because i like over hyped
it so much because it's always top of
mind yeah
but it will ruin your life no it's so
well falling no i know like what do i do
i'm glad i just fell because now i'm not
due for another fall for a little while
i don't know but they're getting closer
and closer together
they're like contractions it's true i'm
[ __ ] like i really and i okay so
here's the thing i was walking behind my
friend game and i fell behind game and i
didn't see him and then when i saw him
at the party like five minutes later i'm
like did you see me fall he said no you
fell and he wasn't just being nice he's
like i swear i literally didn't even see
you fall so the person in front of me
didn't i know you're holding on to hope
but like his back was to you [ __ ] i know
but wouldn't i i'd like made a sound or
something that would have caused him to
turn around was the music loud i don't
know i mean listen you've got to forgive
yourself i can't i really can't i can't
you have to move on because the thing is
nobody else is thinking about it today
except for you i don't know i feel like
some people are just like embarrassing
things happen
like just disassociate say
that wasn't me that didn't happen to me
i'm sorry to this woman yeah no like
that just i
you just can't claim that action yeah it
was just tough because i could ruin my
whole night and i went down and i went
home after like immediately after okay
so that's that we just gotta put it to
bed yeah
just know i'm still thinking about it
constantly okay i'm sorry
it's okay
okay now are you ready to jump in now
that you've let everyone know i've
unburdened myself and i feel like the
more people you tell like the less
embarrassing it is because you're not
like suffering in silence yeah that's
true i i it's really unburdening was the
perfect word that's exactly what i'm
doing the more people i tell like the
less the less said it's my story and
it's ours we all have to shoulder it
yeah yeah and you know that will help me
immensely like take some of the weight
of this burden off of me okay okay
that's what we're here for so without
further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode of the morning toast
is brought to you by noom
noom is here to change how we see food
with a psychology based approach that
makes that looks at what you eat but
also how you eat instead of making you
feel guilt or regret numa is empowering
you to keep going because not everyone
wants to be on a strict diet do two days
at the gym or drink random teas instead
of trying to cram your life into someone
else's idea of health try new they use a
psychology-based approach to find
healthier balance that's moldable to
your life
so you don't need rules to lose weight
and that is the new philosophy they just
require they just give you the knowledge
and wisdom to empower you to build
smarter more sustainable habits their
weight their new weight cognitive
behavioral approach helps you better
understand your relationship with food
and how to be more mindful of your
habits and gives you the knowledge and
support you need for long-lasting change
taking care of your health with noob is
empowering instead of stressful there's
no need to fear ruining the whole
program with one day noon will help you
get back on track and a lot there's a
lot to love about noon but i think the
most
impressive thing about noom is when you
uh look at their food database it's like
the most extensive
um
food database which makes it really easy
to track your food sometimes it can be
really difficult on those random apps
but the new one is very streamlined
they're the biggest database of
different food options and it's just a
premium experience and we know a lot of
people who use noob i know you used it
for a while yes i love noom i think it's
a great resource especially as we head
into the holidays obviously the holidays
can be a bit of a free-for-all and you
should definitely treat yourself and
enjoy but if you want to stay a little
bit on track have a little bit of
accountability or just know what you're
doing i would say noom is the perfect
resource to help you get through this
month start building better habits for
healthier long-term results sign up for
your trial at noom.com toast that's
n-o-o-m-dot-com
toast
thank you claudia it's a pleasure
our first story some exciting engagement
news lindsay lohan announces she's
engaged to bader shamas to a bb bbm to a
businessman beau bmv
lindsay lohan has announced that she's
engaged her boyfriend bader in a gushing
post on instagram the hollywood star
shared the news with her instagram
followers and posted a trio of loved up
snaps the smitten actress paid tribute
to him and wrote alongside her photos my
love my life my family my future at
vader shamas hashtag love
ring emoji cute yeah really cute um
she's like
coming back she's coming back we said
that she has a new christmas movie
coming out with cord over street
sometime soon so that's really exciting
now we're seeing love so you'd love to
see a little personal
success professional success i really
hope that this could be it for her no
it's so crazy when you think about like
those when you think of lindsay lohan
you think of like the it girls of the
early 2000s like paris brittany
lindsay and like they're all settling
down now yeah no they all got engaged
this year yeah 2021 was a great year for
the girls even though i know that
brittany and paris i do not [ __ ] with
lindsay i'm sure yeah i don't expect
they were never like best of friends
they got into a car one night together
no but like they don't like each other
like yeah no but like they
i don't think they were friends they
were friends for sure for a time but
like yeah but powers like paris and
nicole no paris went on watch evans live
a while ago and andy was like say three
nice things about lindsay lohan and she
was like she's lame
tall and something else yeah they don't
get along which but i know britney and
paris do yeah did you see britney like
posted on her instagram something about
jeffree star like i guess he sent her a
ton of makeup and was like congrats
because she like loves his makeup and
she posted just like the collection of
makeup being like thank you jeffree star
i love you like i love your makeup she
deleted it like she's now succumbed to
like cancel culture and she's now
finding out what it's like to really be
on instagram yeah like you thought you
wanted to join us here on instagram no
you did not that's history and then like
jeffree star took his instagram and
being like you guys are bullying someone
who's been in prison for 13 years like
using the free britney movement it's so
messy i'm like not getting involved it's
the stupidest thing ever but it is so
dumb that like she can't just post what
she wants like we're really she's
learning we're canceling brittany now
like leave her alone no that's that's
called being on the internet it wasn't
going to be a free ride
[Laughter]
totally
now you can come play with all of us
and see what we've been going through
um i'm happy for lindsay but by the way
i want to talk about christmas movies
because i actually so last night i
started um
one of the new christmas movies on
netflix called a castle for christmas
with brook shields oh brook shield yeah
i didn't finish it but it was like so
cute and
they just have like the most amazing
budget the budget is unparalleled and
then earlier this week i watched love
hard which is the heather the christmas
movie with nina dobrev and heather
mcmahon and it was so good it was like
funny and like it was how was heather
i've never had her act in anything
heather was the best part i'm sure
that's literally the least surprising
thing she's so funny she was so funny
she wasn't in it enough [ __ ] like okay
it's just a start no but she was so
so good and so funny and then the rest
of the movie like there were some really
funny moments like who plays the man
like love interest oh um i don't know
his name but he was also in
crazy rich asians he was so good and
funny um jimmy o yang let me see
well there's two love interests that's
kind of the point do you know the
premise of the movie
he's like the cousin who um
movies no
not that i know of okay um
there's two love interests that's the
point don't spoil it i don't want to
spoil the premise but it was a really
funny premise it actually got me
thinking mm-hmm about because the
premise is and the show is in the
trailer so this isn't a spoiler i've
seen the trailer it's like a catfish
situation and so she like really like
was into this guy josh lynn
and they were talking for like weeks but
she they hadn't met and then she goes to
meet him and it's not him and the real
guy lives in the town and she's trying
to get now josh to set her up with that
guy and it's like
it really turned for me the catfish
situation on its head because it's like
if you got along with this person like
on every single level and you just like
were disappointed in the way that they
look like that's kind of honestly you
yes but the premise is that that person
lied to you while pretending to be like
open and vulnerable and that's what
bothers people but yes i agree it's like
oh you're actually ugly never mind right
like we agree about everything we
couldn't we have the same sense of humor
same interest you get me on every level
but you just don't look like what i
wanted you to look like well so i think
on the tv show the real problem isn't
that they're ugly and the problem is
that they lied yeah but what if they
lied and they were much more beautiful
like would they be angry
no i totally agree and actually got me
thinking i have a good idea for a dating
app but then i ran it by the snitch and
she said no absolutely not but my idea
is a dating app where there's no
pictures
and you get like the person it's
obviously like name age uh job important
facts and then like some really in-depth
questions that like really give you a
sense of their personality and like if
you saw someone on there who like you
seem so sympatico with would you go out
with them like blind like love is blind
the show
i mean it's an interesting concept and i
think it might be popular like with a
small group of people no only because
and it's terrible to say and it's just
the [ __ ] up world we live in like
looks matter like people have people
have types you like blondes you like
brunettes you like i like a dad bod like
everyone has their interests
and most of the time they
will date within their
type but at the end of the day it's uh
what's on the inside i mean i agree with
that and like and i feel like most
people wouldn't think that at first but
everybody like if you were just like
dating an abercrombie model but they
didn't give you anything mentally
emotionally
intellectually you wouldn't stay with
them no we're mature exactly like we see
that but a lot of people like still
don't like people are very looks
obsessed we live in a society that is
obsessed with like young and skinny and
like we are in a looks obsessed society
and you and i thankfully have risen
above but you know actually was thinking
about that this morning because ben was
sleeping and ben has like a like uh
he's going to kill me he was scared
he has like three like they're like cute
i wouldn't say moe's like birthmarks on
his back they're just like dots like big
freckles and you know i have a personal
aversion to any sort of like marks it
just i have trauma from the three i used
to have um but i was actually thinking
while i was up at 6 30 like ben's bowls
are so cute and like i hate moles and
that's when i realized like how mature i
am how much you love him yeah like i
would if this was another man's back in
my bed i would have vomited like
but when ben i was like these are so
beautiful
we are mature
okay that's the moral of the story
anyways let me guys let me know what you
guys think about my app
name no i i didn't get that far but also
like someone else can create it i'm not
gonna
have the bandwidth to do this so you're
giving the free idea to someone i'm
giving the free idea i think it's a
really interesting cause that show love
is blind like really was the perfect
example of that so why not for
why not in real life why do you have to
go on tv to experience that
yeah no it's true
so those were my thoughts but the movie
was was ultimately really good i laughed
i teared up a little i did i'm also
extremely emotional but i did have a
tear
and
that
to me is the makings of a good christmas
movie i completely a good movie so
congrats to lindsay lohan
no
oh yeah yeah that's the first thing she
wasn't in that movie you know i know but
that's the first story are you ready for
our next story sure some very sad news
off-white designer virgil abloh dies at
the age of 41 after privately battling
cancer for two years so yesterday
virgil's instagram account shared that
quote we are devastated to announce the
passing of our beloved virgil abloh a
fiercely devoted father husband son
brother and friend he is survived by his
loving wife shannon abloh and his
children for over two years virgil
valiantly battled a rare aggressive form
of cancer cardiac angus and geoscoroma
he chose to endure this battle privately
since his diagnosis in 2019 undergoing
numerous challenging treatments all
while helming several significant
institutions that span fashion art and
culture
oh my god this was so surprising it
reminded me exactly of how i felt when
chadwick boseman died because it was the
same thing like such a young guy top of
their game battling something privately
and nobody knew until it was over and it
was just
so sad
and all the tributes that i've read from
other people like are so kind it's like
the nicest things you can say about a
person and of course every time you know
you're writing someone something nice
about someone who's passed away they're
always really nice but everything i was
reading i was just like very like
impacted by they were all just like
above and beyond talking about his
kindness of course his talent like once
in a lifetime once in a generation
talent yeah no it was quite moving to
see what everybody had to say but also
he really is like
the designer of our generation
has lost a great talent
from everything he did with like louis
vuitton men's to off-white like just he
really was a
fixture in the culture and i think we
will feel his loss immensely did you
know that off-white was bought by
farfetch
no because in the statement on the
off-white instagram it said uh off-white
and far-fetched are sad to announce
that's so interesting i know i thought
that was interesting too oh my gosh what
a great merger i know i love both of
those brands so and i also saw on the
louis vuitton instagram that they have
like a show with his final collection
like i will be purchasing like
everything good luck to you no i know
like how do i how do i do it like i just
i want something from like his final
collection you gotta maybe have a sales
person yeah i got a guy i got a guy okay
well this was really sad very sad news
and really surprising yeah put a cloud
over yesterday for sure for sure
are you ready yeah are you ready for our
next story if it's a next story that's
brought to you by overland oh it is um a
family owned american heritage brand
that puts comfort and quality first for
nearly 50 years they offer outerwear
accessories in home decor made from
sustainable natural fibers like
sheepskin leather and wool okay i've
been wearing my slippers all around the
house actually think i've worn them on
the toast a couple times it's the best
pair of slippers slippers are so
important to me holiday seasons coming
up slippers make a great gift for anyone
but also for yourself
overland uses expert craftsmanship to
pair the highest quality merino
sheepskin which is naturally moisture
wiccan
temperature regulating and antimicrobial
with supportive memory foam midsoles in
order to make slippers that feel better
and wear better for longer what sets
overland apart is that they're one of
the only brands in the world to use
double faced sheepskin so the suede you
see outside is the same piece of fluffy
sheepskin as you feel on the inside it's
lighter more breathable and it means
there's no synthetic materials touching
your feet if you want a pair of
well-made comfier than you can imagine
slippers these are the ones to get and
everyone needs slippers it's a perfect
gift for everyone but mostly for
yourself they also offer 100
satisfaction guarantee and their
commitment to customer service is
exceptional so don't wait another day to
slip into something way more comfortable
get the best highest quality sheepskin
slippers on the market at overland.com
toast you'll get free shipping and free
returns and we recommend you go today
because these slippers are very beloved
and they are known to sell out so that's
overland.com
toast overland.com toast take it a
recommendation
i don't know if i ever recommended like
a treadmill i would understand you not
listening to me
i recommend slippers and i recommend
overland they're really great slippers
we were wearing them in the merch shoot
oh yeah no we weren't oh you were i was
wearing a different one yeah yeah
okay are you ready for our next story
sure
so a new book about the royals is coming
out called brothers and wives inside the
private lives of william kate harry and
megan by christopher anderson who is a
source close to the royal family which
part of the family
i think the firm okay and in this book
it says that prince charles is the one
who asked about the skin color of megan
and harry's baby obviously i think any
of us could have guessed that so here's
how the story goes according to the
unless
i just had a thought unless if he's
close to the firm that means that like
the firm like maybe helped with the book
or like had some approval and maybe
charles is already so hated he might be
abdicating like maybe they just decided
to dump it on him that's all i'm saying
so here's the story here's the story and
i think this might uh clear some things
up so prince charles was the unnamed
royal who speculated about the
complexion of megan and harry's future
children according to a new book the
book says a source close to the royal
family claims that charles made the
comment during a conversation over
breakfast with his wife camilla on the
day the duke and duchess of sussex's
engagement was announced so the story is
that there was two of them having
breakfast got it so charles says to
camilla quote i wonder what the children
will look like camilla was said to be
taken aback somewhat by the question and
noted that the child would be absolutely
gorgeous
allegedly lowering his voice charles
then asked i mean what do you suppose
their children's complexion might be a
spokesman for prince charles's office
denied the report saying that this is
fiction and not worth further comment
and then in an interview charles in an
interview on the today show the author
elaborated on the claims in the book
saying
he said that charles's comments were
benign and twisted by palace courtiers
so this was a conversation between
camilla and charles and it got back to
megan and harry via a game of telephone
oh because when when megan and harry
said it i thought they had like a family
meeting and someone was like well what's
a kid's skin color gonna be which is
awful this is still bad but it's
not what i thought right so
he told um hoda and savannah on today
the author he said on the morning that
megan and harry's engagement was
announced in a very kind of benign way
prince charles started to muse on what
their future grandchildren might look
like and the author said quote i mean
here's this beautiful biracial american
woman and the world's most famous
redhead i don't know about that
he said i'm a grandfather of course we
all do this speculate on it but it
turned into something very toxic it was
weaponized by the men in grey who run
the palace organization unfortunately by
the time it got to harry that's the way
he took it and the way he took it is he
said on as he said on oprah that there
were quote concerns and conversations
about how dark archie skin might be when
he's born you know what
it's one of those things like when harry
says it i'm like oh and then when this
man says and i'm like oh like it's just
it's a context thing i guess yes much
like a lot of things yeah but of course
i mean it's really hard and i feel this
way about every single book about the
royal family that comes out like unless
they're writing it themselves it's like
who is writing it how can like they're
so
that was even like finding freedom which
was literal propaganda beyond but like
the whole firm is so close like i don't
i'm inclined not to believe anything
yeah
so i don't know
but this explanation does kind of
it it kind of clears charles a little
bit not well not really because also we
didn't know who it was so it was like it
could have been
but now it's stuck to charles and yes if
you take the time to maybe watch
this guy and maybe you agree with him
then
you could have a little bit of more
understanding about the situation but
i don't think it's good for charles yeah
but i also don't think they just like
put it on him because he's like
a dump the christmas tree oh have you
been watching succession no i'm i want
to scoop a little episodes and watch my
mom on tour because what one in one is
like a little you know what i scooped
them and i had two to watch and it took
me like two days to get through them
because like i think it's the worst show
ever but basically session yeah it's so
bad what like it has all the makings of
a good show because it's on hbo and it
has a really great premise but like it
[ __ ] sucks like if you told me i
watched last night the new episode it's
like if you told me that i could never
watch another episode and i would never
find out what happened i would say okay
wow i'm shocked to hear you say that
it's like it's just really everyone is
so unlikable there's some interesting
like dialogue moments did you know that
tom wobbs gams
is mr darcy from pride and prejudice no
yes somebody put that in the toast
facebook group i was shook i thought mr
darcy was
no that can't be no i'm telling you hold
on
maybe i'm like some maybe in his high
school play no
matthew mcfadden
and matthew mcfadyen mr darcy yeah oh my
god how crazy yeah look at this i see i
see him
oh my god the craziest [ __ ] ever that's
twisted i [ __ ] hated this okay but
even though you know where like where
we're at in succession so it's not um
this isn't a spoiler or anything but
they call tom the christmas tree because
everyone's gonna hang their orange their
eyes on him you know that's literally
charles
and if he ends up like being skipped
which i don't even know if that's
possible like it would all make sense
you know he really took one for the team
after all he's done it's the least you
could do
yeah yeah we'll see and william is just
like so primed and like ready
catherine is ready the country is ready
like the kids are ready they're all set
up like there's literally no need for
charles like if charles mysteriously
disappears in the next couple years
that's why
yeah it's really it's never been done
and the royal experts say that it's not
even a [ __ ] possibility so don't even
think about it but it's crazy because
everyone's thinking about it but it's
like the monarchy is on its last
they can't handle much more and they
need a rejuvenation of excitement
modernization modernization they really
do they need to do something drastic and
i think that that's the perfect solution
because i think the country there i mean
i don't [ __ ] know but
i think people really like william and
kate and would be exciting i think they
do too assure them but it's also just
bizarre the sentiment um on the royal
family here versus in the uk like
whenever i talk to someone british like
they love the family they love the firm
they love will and kate and here like
there's people are find it very
problematic and they're very much
exciting with harry and megan in america
that's why they fled here like they're
the royals here yeah
yeah
i don't know i don't know i guess i'm
just like an anglophile totally you're
such a royalist but i do sometimes like
feel like a francophile
so
is that the right word yeah you love
france yeah it's hard for me because i'm
such an anglophile and such a frank
lapile oh maybe you're just a lover of
tings i think maybe your tinga file i'm
definitely a tingo file and i just think
i'm a lover of the world
a global citizen a global file a global
file yes
okay are you ready for our next story
some exciting news for tick tock kim
kardashian and northwest have launched a
joint tick tock account at kim north it
is racked up more than 130 000 followers
oh you're reading an old article they're
at almost 2 million
oh my god well that was in less than 24
hours and now they're at 2 million and
most notably for me was that they did
the easy on me challenge which we were
joking about well this is an extension
we covered last week on the patreon that
p and courtney had we didn't we talked
about how p got busted oh yeah yeah and
but the account is back up run by
courtney and then i guess because
penelope's mom let her do it north asked
her mom and then kim and north made one
and they're both doing pretty much like
the same content like
really poorly edited like aesthetic
videos of like them just being rich and
sometimes their parents popping in p is
working hard on her account though she
got scott in it i think she got like
travis and when she got alabama alabama
barker in one she got like courtney and
travis in one in the background smart
she's using her surroundings to build
her image and we love that i think that
while i'm happy for pee and that she's
had this found this outlet like i think
that north being like the creative mind
that she is like is just gonna explode i
think this is going to be such a great
vessel for her to ex express herself
she's definitely um just in my tic-tac
opinion she definitely has some more
work to do than penelope on the editing
front like
pretty much everything north post like
isn't in focus and it's really
frustrating maybe that's like an an
aesthetic choice it's possible but i
just think p
has been doing it a little bit longer
she went like undetected on tiktok for
like a week and then it blew up but she
had had a lot of videos on before that
where nobody knew who she was so i just
think she's got a little bit more
experience than north and north could
really use like a tutor because
she's like she did this video i think
she was making her bed like so they went
to palm springs and you know they have
that bunk bed room for all the cousins
to be in at chris's house so she was
like making her bed for an hour on this
tic tac like zooming in on the pillow
like touching the blanket lifting the
blanket lifting the blanket back it was
like pretty torturous
interesting don't
well
i think she's going to do great things
yeah i mean their followings are growing
like is this the start of the kardashian
kids like becoming influencers i think
they're so really yeah no there's so
much more runway i would i think it's
just them having a good time i hope
yeah
and i love seeing kim on the talk like
that's a true right and she's like
dancing which we know she doesn't do and
it's just funny to watch her dance
knowing that she hates it it's just
funny also like when you go on instagram
you go to kim's instagram you get like
business instagram business kim business
business business and this tick tock
version of kim is like mom kim and it's
really sweet it is sweet she's a great
mom yeah she lets the kids do what they
want and they want to talk she'll dance
like she won't dance for anyone she
wants to give her prince but she'll
dance for north
chiggs
jackie
patico erotico hypnotico are you ready
for our fifth and final story
someone doesn't look ready yeah which
way it's been so long since i do the
show do we usually do triangles than ads
or ads and then triangles oh
well looks like we're doing triangles
and ads it's the final story
is and that's a magic number
that's really the craziest factor
in like all year no i know
and i remember watching pride and
prejudice as a kid and first of all
hating it and second of all thinking
like that guy was like falling first i'm
like it should have just been played by
amanda bynes dad i remember thinking
that so clearly like the guy from
what a girl wants totally should have
been mr darcy and this guy was like a
like a cheap knockoff hallmark version
of
colin
first yeah
and now that he's re-entered my life in
this way i'm i'm
besmirched
i don't even know if that's the right
word i think it is
i'm besmirched i'm also mismatched by my
new movement watch
it's almost the holidays and movement
the original watch brand to break all
the rules which was started by two
college dropouts
they've got you covered they're bringing
the sleekest most quality gifts of the
season with hundreds of watches blue
light glasses sunglasses and fine
jewelry
you can stuff your stockings impress
your family and wow your partners or
just treat yourself with the perfect
gift for movement
movement watches are designed in-house
they are super sleek clean and won't
break the bank since they started just
95 so that's probably the best part of
movement is like all their products are
really elegant really well made and the
price point is just not what you expect
it's a lot lower um and that's just nice
when you want to stock up on gifts for
for your dad
partner sister granny anyone they've got
they've really got something for
everyone at movement they have clean
minimal designs and quality products and
they've sold almost
2 million watches in over 160 countries
so it's really a great gift i think the
men's watches are really beautiful and i
got one last year for ben and he loved
it and just nice you know since they're
affordable you can like give a guy
a new watch maybe once a year men love
having lots of watches it's like a dick
thing i don't know
be the big winner this holiday season
with a gift for movement go to
movement.com toast that's mvmt so
mvmt.com
toast join the movement again movement
is spelled mvmt.com
thank you it's a pleasure our fifth and
final story is some crazy book related
news the man accused of raping lovely
bones author alice siebold has his
conviction overturned okay i read this
this morning i told you i don't know if
i mentioned it i was up at 6 30. i was
shocked and i have a lot of questions
because i read the article and it didn't
answer is this the case from the book or
this happened until after not lovely
bones she also wrote lovely bones this
is not about lovely okay okay she just
happens to be the author yes she wrote a
book in 1999 a memoir called called
lucky and was about her sexual assault
which happened to her she wrote that a
stranger beat and raped her in a tunnel
in thornton park near syracuse
university when she was a freshman there
and months later she saw the man um on
the street in the city who reminded her
of her rapist and she reported the
encounter to the police she later wrote
about how she failed to identify the
authority suspect for her rape in a
police lineup but prosecutors later used
her account and microscopic hair
analysis which 35 years later was deemed
faulty as evidence and then this man
anthony broadwater was charged with
forcible rape
alice testified at his trial
so what's she testified on his behalf or
against against him
she but he wasn't the man that she
picked out in the lineup and what's so
crazy about this story that in 2019 it
was reported that lucky was going to be
turned into a movie and earlier this
year the executive producer who was
working on the movie noticed
discrepancies between the memoir and the
script he told the new york times quote
i started having some doubts not about
the story that alice told about her
assault which was tragic but the second
part of her book about the trial which
didn't hang together and so this started
like this chain uh reaction and now a
judge has overturned the conviction but
he was in jail for 16 years anthony
broadwater yes so okay just i'm still
confused
on her part like
so
say it again with the lineup okay so
she
picked someone out of a lineup who
wasn't ultimately the person who was
sent to
jail but the prosecutors i guess
influenced
her choice but the guy she saw on the
street is this guy is this guy but not
the person she picked out of the lineup
yeah and not the person who did it
and we don't know where he is no but she
testified that this was the man yeah
because i guess that's who she thought
or what she thought i i don't know i
didn't see a very bad story i don't like
it yeah no i never read the book lucky
but it was like obviously a huge book it
was going to be turned into a movie was
it after shirt at the lovely bones or
before i think before because this came
out in 1999 and lovely bones was 2002.
got it
yeah
so just a really really crazy story yeah
very sad
very sad like obviously great justice
was served but he
was also in prison for 16 years like you
can't get that time back and that shit's
just not okay yeah
exactly so are they still making it into
a movie i feel like it's like enough i
don't know now the movie has another
twist oh that's true a sequel like
um
[Music]
this is a terrible story yeah really
pittsville yeah majorly pittsfield and i
wonder like
what is her explanation like uh she
hasn't said anything right so i'm sure
she will yeah i think that the um man
was looking hoping for perhaps an
apology
that would be nice
so
we'll see what happens
oh terrible
um
well those are the fast life stories and
i feel as though
you need to know yeah i do i really
really do and the show's not even far
from over because we have so much tv to
talk about yes i think we should just
get out of the way selling sunset that's
like what everyone watch this week
season four or five whatever i can't
keep up is on there's also like another
season coming that they have footage for
because like jason and what's her face
are together but like we didn't get any
of the jason crochet
stupid we didn't get anything we didn't
get anything though i did feel like
there were a few moments of crumbs where
it's like okay jason's in love with i
think they did that intentionally like
every time like rochelle was talking
they would show jason like when she was
flirting with that marvel guy in the
office and jason was like getting all
angry like they were toying with us but
they ultimately gave us nothing
yeah so the season
i really don't even know where to start
because i think it was one of the worst
seasons of tv i've watched in a really
long time which is just so shocking
because i think that like they don't
really have to do much to keep me
entertained like the houses are
beautiful the women are beautiful the
editing is great it's like a gorgeous la
the way that they sin i watched ten
episodes about the same thing and i
didn't get any of the women together
until the last episode was like a
reality tv faux pas no it was really
atrocious um every conversation was
about like the conversation before and
yeah before that and the next one that's
coming well then i had lunch
having lunch my worst
thing i hate most about reality tv i
understand that sometimes you have to
like keep the ball moving but it was the
only thing that was happening there were
no like organic moments that happened i
think that we've all realized that this
show is very much manufactured in the
sense that like these women probably
don't work for the oppenheim group sell
real estate but like you put a bunch of
interesting women in a room together and
shit's gonna start popping off so i'm
fine with that but it was just nothing
nothing happened the only thing that
we're talking about is something that
happened five years ago and i'm having a
hard time even believing that that even
happened because what are the odds that
the man that christine's boyfriend was
the woman that the christine's boyfriend
was cheating on her with also works at
that point also works at the oppenheim
group and everybody knows her except but
this was christine's first time ever
seeing her yeah so i feel like they made
up that whole situation and then so
christine made up some more on her own
side so here like when it boils if i
really have to get into the weeds and
like chew and dissect this idiocy which
i was just so uninvested i don't even
care to have an opinion but if i had to
my opinion would be this
christine is acting very bizarre and her
story is not adding up like she said the
real like
kink in the armor was when she said like
davina i was friends with divina she
knew i was engaged and then davina was
like no if davina's not even backing him
up like you're [ __ ] so i think that
like she's definitely making some [ __ ]
up and she's
really not interested in being friends
with these girls and she acted very
bizarre and i really couldn't get behind
her but more than that i couldn't get
behind the
massively loser energy that was just
radiating from mary radiating from
kichelle radiating from heather like the
way christine who they claim to despise
is living so rent free in their minds
makes me actually have a lot of sympathy
for these enormous losers like so for me
i know everyone's so focused on
christine being like caught in her lives
and i see that but i raise you the
loseriest losers who ever losered no the
loser is losers and you know what i
actually the season weirdly made me like
heather moore then i liked her in the
past that is so weird that you said that
because i was actually like really
vibing on heather like i just was liking
her energy and even when she was with
the loser brigade she was being the she
was above it a little bit the least bit
of a loser like mary and christelle are
obsessed with christine there needs to
be like the bechdel test for the show
like the quinn test
is there people on the show who are not
christine quinn yes do they ever have a
conversation where christine quinn is
not mentioned no fails the [ __ ] test
not once do they get together and they
do not bring up christine
it's crazy like loser and it's just so
crazy how like christelle is like
everyone's queen when it's like i think
her like and even all the vibe in the
office and i understand where christine
is like coming from where it's like
everybody just sits there being so
[ __ ] fake with their fake laughs and
their fake smiles like with fake girl
boss women empowerment and it's like
so cringy and not authentic and then
they accuse christine of being not
authentic i'm like at least she tells
you how she feels like you guys just
like sit around being fraudulent being
fraudulent just wanting to like come off
well on tv or whatever yeah but it's
like
it's so crazy the way they talk to each
other in the office like those aren't
real conversations no that's not
real human interaction and the way like
they're just so like sing-songy the
whole time and then they're like go
[ __ ] boss babe yeah like
that is my least favorite and i think
rochelle really said it best
empowered women
empower women no it's like i could die i
could vomit like
it's a pattern powered women don't say
that empowered women don't talk about
being empowered they just are it's a
parody of like
feminism yeah and girl power and
cringe-tastic i can't believe there are
people out there who are like inspired
by this no and you know what i really
have had enough and i don't think i can
really ever watch a tv show ever again
that mary is on she is a disgrace like
she's the worst dressed woman on the
planet and it's only
highlighted more because everyone even
davina brought it up a notch like
everyone is just sickening that girl
emma like outfit outfit evan heather
looks so cute all the time christine
affidavit christelle looks great really
professional
mary is like shopping at a different
store and you know what it's just
something about mary like there's
something about mary
because when they went to that fashion
showroom and they literally walked out
in the same dress
oh they were going to two different
places like literally what's her name
christelle was going to the oscars she
looked so great in it and mary was going
to the diner like mary just like
cheapens everything and then when she
starts to talk it like is so much worse
i'm sorry i'm really going off no i
can't stand her she's a bully too and
when all these girls they just cry and
like make and christine was doing that
too like just crying and making us and
something weird about like seeing
christine cry do you agree like yeah but
it's just not adding up so i need to go
back to mary at the um
at the albright library because she's
surrounded by gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous
tanks pick up pick out uglier things
mary i dare you couldn't be uglier but
that scene of her and christelle like
when they both put on the metallic
dresses and they were talking about how
they were super women and what would our
superpowers be i don't think there's a
cringier moment in television history
like and i'm sorry but if that
if that scene warmed your heart or made
you feel like warm and fuzzy look inward
i was literally
and they were literally i wish they
would have like it was cringeness 2.0
like it was
if she's coming to the party tonight oh
yeah they did talk and by the way what
the two of them end up actually wearing
to the party there's no way they got it
from [ __ ] patricia fields warehouse
right there totally they looked really
not great they all look stupid running
around that house like fashion this
season like it's amazing emma was
she was giving us so much barbie
christine gives us everything i agree
christelle has her sense of style that's
super cute heather too
mary not so much amanda always looks
great yes and oh my god what a crazy
[ __ ] that's going on
yeah first of all i don't even think she
set foot in like one house like she
didn't work she wasn't uh
selling selling she was doing
interior design and also dealing that
was the craziest thing like how he just
literally sent a letter and was like i
give up all legal rights to my kids so
he'd have to pay child support like
that's so sad crazy she's a really good
mom i actually really like her
especially because she's like the only
one who's like someone in the middle
yeah and that she like i so christine up
until this season and still the season
like this is my absolute favorite on the
show before this season i was like
christine kaduna christine's a queen
this season i'm like she's making it
hard for her fans to defend her because
like what the [ __ ] is this story yeah um
but i still
would i'm still team christine over all
of the other women they are so obsessed
with her it's crazy they're obsessed and
they can't take her like they were like
well we want to speak to you as a group
which is obviously not a fair fight
because they don't want her to get away
with her lies but like okay speak to her
one-on-one and call her out on her life
but that's not why they want to speak to
her like that's just a lie they made up
they just want to speak to her all
together so they can be ganged up when
they were in the car they were like we
have each other's backs like it's easy
to talk to anyone even the most person
who hasn't done anything wrong if it's
three against one right and it's like
they don't realize this and i'm sure i
feel like a lot of people don't feel
this way i know i'm in the minority here
but like they are the mean girls
whenever it's everyone against one
person and one person feels alienated
and even like christine i feel like
eventually she lets her walls down it's
like do you know how hard it is to walk
into a room where everyone hates you she
did it so many times this season and was
like so you know i guess fake and like
smiley and hi everyone how are you
giving everyone hugs but like
that [ __ ] sucks
and yes she did but also
i wish they would be more specific about
what christine did to the other women
yeah like so we know that uh we know she
said some [ __ ] about tariq you know in
the cupcakes whatever yeah called the
relationship like stupid when christelle
says that she tried to like ruin her
reputation ruin her as a person at the
time when her parents were
both passed away what did she do i don't
know
they needed to be more specific because
i i couldn't sympathize if i don't know
the crime it makes it seem like you're
just like making stuff up the thing is
it's like i don't really ride or die for
christine anymore like not close to how
much you do but i don't think she's
necessarily in the right i just refuse
to be on the side of the three biggest
losers in the history of television
therefore by the transitive property
makes me team christine yes and i will
say in order of loseriness it goes well
let me hold on let me series one
merry christine emma no no christelle
that's what i meant yeah mary christelle
emma and then i would put uh heather
heather but she really didn't bother me
until the end she like stormed down like
had a moment and tarek is like so trying
to make something happen like it's fine
she's she's an idiot like she's just
like calm down tara but i do think uh
heather and tariq are match made in
heaven 100 persons they seem really
happy
i'm happy for them and it definitely
changed
my pov
about them i wish them a lifetime of
love i agree even now i really
understand how there's mindless news
like
it it's really i think just like what
they do on a daily basis like dumb
things you know and they're so excited
about like little things that they're
doing together and they just want to
share it i'm totally fine with them so
that was a turning point for sure um but
just even emma who i thought was going
to come in and like be really cool as a
person just went on the loser train choo
choo choo choo bringing her empanadas
everywhere and i did look up her vegan
food company because she acted like she
was super successful of course she's
skinny girl and i just wanna let you
know she's not i just wanted to clear
the air for everyone she's not super and
of course like she has to say that she
finds private because she needs to take
her big dog with her but there was a dog
birthday party and she didn't even bring
him and that to me just like didn't add
up it's also a tv show like she's not
flying private first of all like even if
your vegan food company like is really
successful like do you know how
expensive it is to fly from boston to la
multiple times a month it's like 50
grand every time i'm sorry she's just
not doing that yeah also when mary like
had a connection that christine mary is
just erratic
when she had a conception that christine
came to the dog party oh she's acting
like a lunatic christine was so well
behaved and then when the two of them
are at the albright
closet and they're like well maybe if
christine comes she could be drama free
and they're like has she ever been every
single time christine showed up this
year there was no [ __ ] drama it was
just like mary and chris spinning their
wheels oh you know who like got on tv
and got like a little empowered
christine's husband
he's like they're just jealous babe like
you're married they're divorced they
wouldn't dream of taking trips like we
do on our weekends like right i was just
kind of like it was also really weird
that they had that conversation in the
middle of the street yes like you guys
have a house that's beautiful and quiet
and you go and if you want to talk [ __ ]
do it there it's crazy how frequently
people in light just move
yeah and actually christelle's house
that she ended up getting is really nice
like thomas canyon yes and i'm happy i'm
so happy for krishele that she has a
place of her own it's a wonderful thing
like to
to be able to own a home without anyone
being able to take it away that part i
actually liked yeah she became every
episode just like losery and loser
the whole world is lying to her and and
but people really feel this way about
her where she's like america's
sweetheart and i'm really every season i
was like you know what christelle's
gonna have an amazing season like she's
such a big star dancing with the star
she looks amazing she's like you know
she's moved on from her heartbreak and
she's in this like new season of her
life and she was still a big loser and
i'm i just can't i can't either like it
was there was so much cringe so much
cringe and the way she acts around
celebrities like it's inappropriate
actually like for the workplace but i do
i could see how jason is in love with
her i was like maybe i was editing but i
was like okay
also that guy from marvel was in love
with her and the basketball player right
and she should have gone out with a guy
from marvel and also the basketball
player was really hot she should have
went out with him too yeah
maybe she did yeah but she's very flirty
like touching and i was like i don't
think this is appropriate wheelchair
conductor no and like are you really
supposed to hug your realtor every time
you see them 100 i don't even like to
like hug you every time i see you like
it's really weird yeah no there was a
lot of hugging a lot of inappropriate
like workplace condoms especially in the
pandemic especially on behalf of gracel
yeah i agree but like they're just like
a hugging bunch over there totally and
oh my god the shoes like i don't like
how they walk around these houses and
these all these houses in l.a they're
like ice castles like they're not warm
there's no carpet it's like hard corners
and hard marbles stairs for flights of
lights upstairs i'm like and they're
walking the crazy shoes and you know
what like davina's been trying to keep
up with the looks like she obviously
went to stuart's and like bought
everything those like tweed looking
dresses that everyone got but she could
not walk in heels have you noticed that
about her like she's trying so hard to
keep up she physically cannot yeah oh
wait we didn't even talk about christine
the pregnancy
and the rumors that she faked it i
really don't like to entertain like
conspiracy theories like that like it's
moronic and offensive and
i don't think she faked her pregnancy i
don't think she faked her pregnancy
either i think that and people even if
she didn't fake her pregnancy people are
like upset with her that she's like you
know putting out this like standard of
postpartum that is just so [ __ ]
unattainable but it's like i feel like
and i'm pregnant right now and i love
seeing christine two days out of labor
like walking down the street
like head to toe and because that's
really what she did and like i feel like
i see so many realistic portrayals of
what postpartum actually is whether it's
on instagram or like on tv movies books
like you know that it's really not very
easy very unfabulous yeah
but it is kind of cool to see this like
person who really is just having this
incredibly fabulous experience i know
that's not going to be me but like it
gives you a little friendship it's it's
hopeful yeah i mean i did not find it
offensive whatsoever no me neither and i
mean i'm not pregnant so i don't know
what it's like but like also like that's
really what we're arguing about like
there's much bigger problems in the
world it's really like it's crazy and
also she really did work out like
through her entire pregnancy she was
doing pilates literally a week before
she gave birth like if that person
is going to be perfect after they give
birth they deserve it if that's what it
takes yeah i won't be doing that right
and that's why i won't look anything
like that right but i really like i
found it to be so interesting to just
watch her postpartum journey be so
radically different
from anyone else on earth it looked
tiring i just wish like the heel she
would cool it with
when she was super super pregnant like
walking around
like town in those shoes it's actually
giving me terrible anxiety like one snap
of an ankle so dangerous yeah i agree
but that's christine she was literally
on another level
this season yes she was um
also the real housewives of potomac uh
finale was last night and nicki minaj
joined us and i have a lot to say
so
the nicki minaj reunion is brought to
you by hush all right let's talk about
the quality of your sleep the reality is
we've been talking about it over 160
million million americans struggle with
sleep and hush is here to help they're
an industry-leading sleep brand that
carries a wide range of sleep essentials
for every sleeper whether you're a hot
sleeper or a cold sleeper hush has what
you need to get the job done so they
carry everything from pillows and sheets
to their best-selling weighted blankets
and mattresses and they even have their
iced technology which keeps you cool all
night long in their iced weighted
blanket and their mattress so if you're
looking to improve your rest your
nightly rest naturally hush is the
answer i actually have a lot of products
from hush of course i have the weighted
blankets which are the best i've had
them for a while i have silk pillowcases
which is so great for your hair skin
face everything
pillow blankets i also have the iced
sheets because i'm very cognizant of
my temperature at night and the fact
that there is a brand that's making
products for your bed that is catered to
like sweaty necks is really really
lovely um it's also a great gift holiday
season is coming
it's a great way to show your loved ones
that you care about them something that
is also really important to hush is uh
from day one they've donated one in ten
adult products and one in five kids
products to those in need around the
world so if you're looking to upgrade
your sleep head over to hushblankets.com
they have a huge black friday sale
happening right now so make sure to
check them out before the sale ends
that's hush blankets.com to take
advantage of the black friday sale
amazing so nikki wrapped it up last
night she was like coming hard and like
dying on random hills yeah they weren't
my hills no and i just thought it was
weird because like okay she was first of
all i thought the conversation about
michael sexuality which like of course i
think a lot of people wonder it was just
like really inappropriate to have right
in front of ashley and it was like kind
of [ __ ] rude and i just didn't like
it i agree and i just felt like with
every woman she like poked and prodded
at the worst thing like yeah that's not
what we we needed you here like to be
our voice and you're just like talking
about random [ __ ] yeah gisele and robin
being lovers that's so
stupid like so stupid i agree i liked
her presence i liked her energy and i
love how much she loves the show clearly
and and knows everything that has
happened but it's just i didn't feel
like she was speaking for me she wasn't
speaking facts and also because like she
got this position because of you know
justice for monique
and it wasn't mentioned no but that
scene with candace singing like was
truly painful first of all
the fact that she was so hesitant and
like wouldn't sing her own song was so
bizarre so bizarre because she has we
hear her singing she's an amazing voice
she sings on the show happy birthday
like oh my god can no one have a
birthday without candice i think that
i'm the candace of the morning toast and
of course if nicki minaj was like sing
toast by claudia actually like i would
die and i would feel so awkward i
probably wouldn't do great but i
wouldn't say no yeah
it was weird like i was just weirded out
and then she did it she didn't sound
amazing she sounded decent but she was
obviously really nervous she was a
little pitchy but it was fine my god is
chris bassett such a [ __ ] drama queen
or what like coming in what you're mad
at nicki minaj do you think she [ __ ]
cares right it was that was a weird
moment but it was actually nice of andy
to come over
yeah because like nikki really did put
her on the spot and she was visibly
uncomfortable like nikki doesn't care no
and like it was painful for everyone and
i can imagine it was actually really
painful to be there and i thought it was
cool that like andy came over and like
congratulated her and was like calm down
you're gonna be fine yeah and at the end
of the day like you perform for nicki
minaj like how many people can say that
once in a lifetime i agree it really i
was so excited for mickey's presence and
then it just it didn't give me what i
needed just because
she was going off on things that really
didn't bother me no and like she just
chose like one or two issues with every
woman
and like i didn't even notice half the
[ __ ] that they were talking about like
she was just
like going on tangents about the most
irrelevant things like i wanted her to
go with candace like really talking
about her anger and the common
denominator the monique of it all like i
would have loved nicki's take on that i
would have loved nikki's take on like
wendy being so rehearsed this season
like with her weird tic toc
then when like i would have loved nicki
to like go in on her i also thought
nicki like paid a lot of respect to
karen and put giselle a little in her
place like it's like enough already with
like the age jokes like you're obsessed
with karen yeah and that karen was the
only one who didn't really get anything
bad from nikki which made the whole
thing worth it yeah i agree it was nice
to see respect justice for karen at
least if we can't get it
karen got a spin-off with her family oh
excited did you know that i don't think
so yeah camera guy's been up and also
last night porsha her show
she got a spin off after atlanta
premiered there was a lot of promo for
it but i watched it it was very good oh
exciting exciting exciting you'd love to
see like who gets a spin-off and who
doesn't it's like the most interesting
game in the world yes but ultimately
like i'm glad that nikki
showed up and that that was something
that we got to see you know i
i would like i'm open for more in the
future with other major celebrities who
are big fans of a franchise please do
not overdo it do not ruin a good thing
because it was just like a fun exciting
thing yeah that happened and even though
i didn't like feel like i got what i
needed what i needed it was something
new
and that's so great and we were a part
of something we were and it was like
exciting yeah it was um so i told you
mia was just all over like i know i
really was like rooting for the
beginning of the season and then like it
got so hard to root for her and i was
thinking to myself i'm like why am i
rooting for this person like yeah i'm
getting nothing from it no she's like
she's insane yeah she really is and then
when she was like oh by the way like the
scene where where nicki was like asking
um candace about like how many
drops i mean how many albums she sold
and nikki
nikki was like you sold 500 000 like
adele's album just now
had 622 000 which is the biggest this
year like so candace you're telling me
like your song got 500 000 purchases and
even 20 000 is a lot yeah but i think
that that was the real number and that's
a really good number yeah yeah that
conversation made me want to die yeah
but i thought candace actually handled
it pretty well yeah because you put it
on the spot like
you could just tell who nicki liked and
who she didn't like she doesn't like
candace she likes karen i think she
likes robin and giselle
she doesn't like ashley no what the hell
oh man that was crazy he likes wendy
yeah see that's why i just didn't agree
yeah agreed um okay so i told you about
the jonas brothers rose like please do
not waste your time i'm going to watch
it first of all
they advertised like all these comedians
gabrielly iglesias gabriel
was not in it he was in like a little
stupid like clip in the credits
basically like the
the flow of the night was like some
people came out and roasted like lily
singh came that was a
that was a tough one um
priyanka did a pretty good job sophie
did like an okay job danielle jonas like
all the wives did it but then like
danielle jonas was like had a bunch of
cue cards up and she was like i lost my
voice and then she roasted him on the
cue cards but obviously she is like
nervous because she's like not a
performer she's not an entertainer yeah
it's like in front of like a big crowd
of 100 people
overall it was just so stupid like there
would be a roast and then they'd cut to
like a package you know so they did this
thing with like you know joe and niall
horan did like undercover soul cycle
moronic kevin did you know football
training at the rams sofi stadium
moronic like
there was so little roasting like
traditional stand-up roast some of it
was good they had this british comedian
i never heard of jack white wall or
something hilarious but how was pete
davidson when he made that one funny
joke yeah that was it like that's
literally the extent of his time on the
thing yeah there's nothing it's like he
was so good and he's at the beginning so
me and ben were like so excited he left
comes back for one tiny little segment
that's it oh my god so it was just and
then john legend came like roasted in a
song which was like a cute idea
but no like none of it was working i was
really surprised
damn i'm still gonna watch it but i
guess my expectations have been lowered
yeah they should and overall like my
takeaway is like joe is still my
favorite
okay i like you know what i think then
kevin
then frankie
then nick
um you watch anything else yes
no i read golden girl by ellen
hildebrand the book you raved about
um
and i liked it i mean now that i've
really sat with it i thought it would be
more on my mind and like it's not i
agree with that it's not on my mind
because it was this kind of like deep
book about like the afterlife and i
loved that part of it i thought it was
like really like a nice
wait way of thinking about like people
who have passed away how like you know
they're not really worried about you or
like in pain they're just like at peace
i loved that
but
you know my biggest complaint with the
book was that it was unbelievably long
and i was actually texting with
rockhampton we oh every every book you
recommend me i recommend to her and she
loves your recommendations by the way
she just did it happened one summer
i told her i'm like it's a little
pornographic she said it's fine so then
i was like i read golden girl by ellen
hildebrand i think you would like it but
like it is really long like pages and
pages of descriptions just walking into
a restaurant okay she's like i can't do
it like i it's my deal breaker like i
can't so now i'm looking back on the
book with like hatred in my eyes just
because it took up so much of my time
but like it also was a good book like
the plot twist like it was great the
concept was great but now i like i just
have like hate in my heart for it got it
the way that i feel is i do think it was
too long and it could have been shorter
but i was enjoying it so much and i
haven't really been so into a book in so
long that it was like why would i want
this to end yeah let's keep going i know
but even like the best book in the world
like all good things must end yeah but i
it was my favorite ellen hildebrand book
that i've ever read and i read the whole
winter and paradise series we read
perfect couple which is so good is it
the wedding one that's the wedding one i
love that one i liked it better i read
28 summers i think that's what i'm going
to read next i like this one the best
and i would recommend it to everyone but
speaking of books we just recorded our
final redheads episode
of the year we read the midnight library
by matt haig and i'm just gonna give you
a little spoiler which was that all four
of us loved it oh good it was so good
dana's choice it was a dana's choice and
obviously she always hits it out of the
park so not only do we recap the book
but it was and it was a book like also
about the afterlife so just really
interesting thought-provoking
discussions about like parallel
universes and like what happens when we
when we go and every decision that you
make in life how it affects like the
rest of your life where would you be if
you know i didn't go on that teen tour
that's what martha
in the book helps you with right it's
actually quite similar but the midnight
library is shorter it's well i like it i
think that you would it's a snitch it
liked it so if snitch liked it i think
you would like it it's written
perfectly like there's not a wasted
sentence love that every sentence that
is packed with meaning
anyways we recap that book and then we
do our 2021 year in review of books we
each give our fav top three redheads
books of the year and top three
non-redheads books of the year was my
book this year it was technically yeah
right okay
but it was also in like the poll oh that
was march madness that was yeah that was
all redhead's books got it so this was
just 20 21.
get included in your you know we didn't
mention it
because i read it in 2012 like to me
yeah when i went through my goodreads
i've i rated it in 2020 so it's
satisfied yeah but i actually should
have because i was coming up short with
like what to
make i didn't know anyways girl with no
job.com book
and there's a redheads episode about
that anyways new episode of redhead
shops on thursday it's literally so long
if you don't want read the book and
don't want to um you can listen we recap
the book or
you can skip to the 2021 year in review
part because
i think we got a delicious
it looks like we have a delivery that's
so delicious anyways we just talk about
all the books that we read this year all
of the best books of the year and it's
really good
oh
we just got like a sickening delivery
okay get back here give me mine
this is the tim hortons justin bieber
collab tim biebs you see
tim bits is what they call their
munchkins is there any food in here yeah
oh [ __ ] yes
i know you guys love how we us eating
and getting ooh what is this there's
also
oh a pouch it's their munchkins that's
okay so do you know tim hortons yes i do
it's like the dunkin donuts
what flavor is that it's like birthday
cake with
stuff on it
do you think haley eats these yeah oh
they're all the same flavor and there's
also oh my god these smell so good
hold on we'll like them
oh a fanny pack
oh my god
this is so good you know birthday cake
is like my favorite flavor this is so
cool is it a fan do you know we were
getting this no how'd they get the
address
that is so bizarre
did you give them no
i think you did i so where to god i do
not
well thank you thanks justin
well i'm done are you done i'm done
that's our show you guys thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
milania morning show
where we deliver the fast life stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast and we're podcasting we found so
that's part of our itunes center public
radio i hear we do chest blocks all the
places wherever you listen podcast five
nights morning chelsea five star you
better beautiful sunny and smart we are
love you guys we'll see you tomorrow bye